tonight allows people a release for all
the hatred and violence if they keep up
inside why don't you guys kill someone
tonight
because we don't feel the need to Johnny
just remember all look at the perch does
we'll be fine just like always no
worries okay this is your emergency
broadcast system announcing the
commencement of the annual purge at the
siren all emergency services will be
suspended for 12 hours your government
thanks you for your participation please
it's just easy to mistake
why did you let him in our home we have
no idea who's after him our target for
this is part is hiding in your home you
have one hour to find it and getting to
us or kill all of you I can't get in
here right they can't get into our home
you
you
we're gonna make it through tonight and
everything is gonna be okay nothing is
ever going
the perch looks like an awesome movie it
looks really scary it looks super
[ __ ] suspenseful it just looks like
an intense mother [ __ ] picture ethan
hawke looks like he's gonna do some
solid leading work in this film I know
he already did sinister with these guys
and I'm sure he's gonna deliver yet
again and if i'm not mistaken i remember
he cheated uma thurman after this movie
we will forgive him completely there's a
lot of other actors in this movie who
I've never heard about that works very
well for a horror film because the less
famous someone is the more scary the
movie is I just love the concept of this
picture it's such a great Hollywood
high-concept what if plot I mean think
about it you really get you wondering if
we were allowed to commit crime once a
year would we actually go through with
it looks like we really debate about the
psychology of this his movies also rated
R for strong violence and you know
honestly I'm not the kind of guy that
really loves strong violence except when
it's dominatrix but for a film like this
you're definitely gonna want it to be
very violent and I'm just going to throw
it out there I think crime should be
legal once a year so i can [ __ ] as many
hookers as i want to let me get straight
to the point here i'm going to take a
gamble here and say the purge will get
it right
alright guys thanks for checking out my
trailer review why don't you go ahead go
to that comment box below and tell me
your thoughts about what you think about
the upcoming flick the purge and last
but not least if you want to get updated
every time one of my trailer reviews
this out or one of my movie reviews is
out please go ahead and click that
subscribe button right here